سنتحدث عن اثمن المعادن التي لطالم مرتبطه
بالمناسبات السعيده انه الذهب
في هذا الموضوع من المعروف ان رفع السعر
الفائده يكون له تاثير على ارتفاع سعر
الدولار وفي المقابل يؤدي تضخم الى
التقليل والحد من طلب الناس على السلع ما
يؤدي الى حدوث انخفاض في سعر الذهب ولكن
ما يحدث في مصر امر مختلف فالمصريون
يتحصنون بالذهب فيسعت تجار الى تحقيق
مكاسب كثيره بسوق الذهب في مصر ما يؤدي
الى حدوث قفزات كبيره في سعر الذهب فيما
تتبع الدوله جهودا للتحكم في الاسعار
ومنها الغاء رسوم تسمين الذهاب لتشجيع
التصدير وطرح الذهب عيار 14 رسميا
بالاسواق لمكافحه غلاء السعر الاخرى وذلك
بعد ان حقيقه هذه العيال نجحت عندك في
اسواق ذات ذوق رفيق منها او رفيع منها
تركيا وايطاليا المزيد مع سمر باشا شهد
الذهب له اهميه خاصه عند الاسره المصريه
فهو الهديه القيمه شبكه العروس ولا ادخار
الامن للمستقبل
هو جميل مجوهرات جميله وطبعا ادخار يعني
قبل اي شيء
بالنسبه لمصر صناعه الذهب والمجوهرات طور
جدا فيها وخاصه في العشر سنوات الاخيره
صارت منافسه عالميه جدا بالنسبه لمنتجاتا
لاذواق لاوزانا وانتل السوق العالمي
والارتباك شهدتها اسواق الذهب في الفتره
الاخيره حيث ارتفع سعر جرام الذهب الارقام
غير مسبوقه نتيجه للتضخم المحلي والعالمي
ما اثر على حركه البيع والشراء
ارتفاع سعر العمله والتضخم جعل من الذهب
القيمه المضمونه وليس فقط للزينه
شايف ان هو مخزن جيد للقيمه يعني على اساس
ان هو ارتفاع الاسعار هتبقى الجنيه لما
ينخفض يبقى هو محتفظ بنفسه بالفلوس
اللي هي البناتي كده اشتري يعني البسها
بعدين والشراء لا مش باشتري اسعار الذهب
لا دي حاجه مش مش منطقيه خالص ودي رافعه
مش عاديه الاول
بسعر
الدولار طبعا مش مستقره في البنك يعني مش
عارفين اسعار ماشيه ازاي هو ده هو الفتره
دي طبعا
وبعدما كان الذهب من عيار 18 21 هو السائد
في السوق
ظهر عيار 14 واصبح له زبائنه لانخفاض سعره
اقل من عيار 18 هو عيار 14 في 60 في الميه
من الذهب و 40% من الاضافات الثقافه في
مصر بقت متعوده على عيار 14 بدات سالت
عليها في المحلات القطاعي كانت الحكومه
المصريه في الايام الاخيره قد الغت الرسوم
على الصادرات الذهب والمقدره بنصف في
المئه لتشجيع التصدير المشغولات الذهبيه
المشهوره عند المصريين منذ العهد الفرعوني
وما زالت تشكل جزءا مهما من عادات الحياه
اليوميه ومنها الزواج ما ادى الى تعالي
الاصوات المطالبه للاسر بعدم المغالاه في
تحديد قيمه الشبكه للتسير على الشباب
[موسيقى]
هيروح يجيب ذهب ولا يفرق الشقه ولا في ظل
ارتفاع الاسعار اللي حصل
الذهب واصبح الان على راس قائمه اهتمامات
المصريين سمر باشات لصباح العربيه من
القاهره
[موسيقى]
نتعرف معكم على ذهب عيار 14 هذه المره
مزاياها عيوبه والفرق بينه وبين ذهب عيار
الثمانيه عشر عيار 18 يحتوي على 75% من
الذهب الخالص اما عيار 14 فيتكون من نسبه
58% من الذهب الخالص
ينتشر عيار 14 من الذهب في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بريطانيا والغرب بشكل
كبير حيث يمثل عيار 14 حوالي 90% من
مشتريات الامريكيين لخواتم الخطوبه يتميز
لها عيار 14 بصالباته وذوقه الرفيع من
ناحيه التصميم ووفقه للخبراء فهو ذو اللون
الاقرب الى اللون الذهبي المعروف عند
الجمهور مما يجعل الفتيات يميلون اليه عند
الاقبال على الشراء قبل معرفتها
كما يتميز لها بعيار 14 بتكلفته المتواضعه
مقارنه بالاعيار الاخرى كذلك يعتبر الاعلى
مكانه والاكثر قدره على تحمل معيار 18 في
الذهب مست كنقائه العالي فيه يجعل يجعله
اقل احتماليه لتسبب في حساسيه الجلد
لاصحاب البشره التي تاثر سريعه
براز عيوب الذهب عيار 18 كونه انعم اسهل
للخدش في الاضافه الى سعره المرتفع
انا 14 شمارق عليها
عبد العظيم الامويه المتخصص في الاسواق
الماليه والمعادن الثمينه اهلا بك منورنا
يا مرحب مرحب صباح النور
الاصول المغريه للمستمرين اليوم فضل
تقلبات في السوق وتقلبات في السعره الى
المدرسه
انا افتكر انه الاستثمار في الذهب هو يعني
تنطبق عليه شروط الاستثمار العامه مع بعض
الخصوصيات الخاصه بالذهب والذهب كما هو
معلوم منه يعني عندنا اجسام محدده
او اشكال المحدده من ال- اا من الطلب
واشكال محدده ايضا من معدن الذهب واشكال
المختلفه يعني مثلا هنالك بعض في السوق
المحلي في دبي مثلا
فهنالك اوزان مختلفه تبدا من
11جرام احنا نسميها هنا التوله 11.6
وعندنا التيتي بار 112 وعندنا الوقيه هذه
الاشكال المختلفه الاختلاف في الاسعار
ايضا كما ذكرت في التقرير ويعود لي درجه
النقاء او الفيروتي بالنسبه للذهب
فبالتالي وهذا جانب الاستثمار هنالك ايضا
لا نسجانب الذهب المشغول اولي ايضا لديه
كثير من التفاصيل الخاصه
استاذ عبد العظيم اليوم بدنا نحكي معك
مثلا بشغله شخص ما بيفهم بالذهب يعني ما
بفهم انه فكره ذهب طلع او ذهب نزل خلينا
نبسط الفكره من منطلق انه الذهب زينه
وخزينه هل هو الوقت المناسب للاستثمار
بالذهب اليوم
نحن يعني تابعنا مثلا من 20 20 الازمه
الماليه العاليه الكرونه وبعدها الازمه
الروسيه الاخرانيه التقلبات التي حدثت في
الثلاث سنوات الماضيه دفعت اسعار الذهب
للارتفاع الى مستويات غير مسبوقه في العام
الماضي تجاوزت الوجيه الواحده 2000 و74
الان هنالك اضرب حصل في هذه السنه تقريبا
الى 1,600 للوجيه
المستويات الحاليه انا افتكر انها مستويات
جيده بالنسبه للاستثمار همم على امل ان
هنالك احتمالات متوقعه للاسعار في 20 23
هذا على صعيد السير ولكن اذا المواطن
البسيط اراد ان
اين يذهب او كيف ماذا يشتري طب مثلا هنالك
بعض
التكس المؤثره مهمه تبسه مهمه في كل ما
كانت همم الاوزان قليله كل ما كانت هنالك
يعني المصنعيه اعلى حتى بالنسبه للسباكه
القصيره فبالتالي على الشخص ايضا ان يختار
ان يضع فلوسه في في قطعه المصنعيه فيها
اقل ودائما نحن نفضيمن التوله واعلى تيكي
بارو اعلى
ذهب
البسي عبد العزيز
المستقبل ولسهوله بيعه انا اليوم بدي
اشتري ذهب اشتري كمان
مشغولات يدويه هذه سؤال ايضا جديد ممتاز
جدا مشكله المشغولات فيها مصنعيه عاليه
جدا احنا بنتابع دائما كل ما ارتفعت اسعر
الذهب كل ما زادت المصنعيه وكل ما انخفضه
المصنعيه
لكن تشارج مصنعيه الذهب يعني
الذهب ب2000$ وكان اسعار الذهب عاليه
دائما يحط عليها مصنعيه اعلى فبالتالي
الذهب المشغول هذه هي الميزه التنافسيه
التي تفقده او ميزه تنافسيه اقل السبايك
افضل واكثر ضمانا ولا توجد فيها ممكن
افضل عبد العظيم اليوم مثلا في ظل كل هذه
التقليبات والتضخم ورفع سعر الفائده وكل
ما يحصل في العالم ما هي العوامل التي يجب
ان اتنبه لها الصعيد شخصي بان الذهب اليوم
سوف يرتفع او ساعه سيخبط بناءا على ذلك
اتوجه لشراء الذهب
المهمه جدا همم همم تحرك اسعار الذهب على
المدن المتوسط والطويل العوامل المهمه سعر
الدولار الامريكي اصبح في السنوات الماضيه
كان واحد من الدواء التي تدفع الذهب
للارتفاع والانخفاض العامل الثاني ايضا
التقلبات الاقتصاديه ذاكره هنالك احتمالات
ازمه يعني مثلا احنا في الاقتصاد بنتوقع
انه 20 23 احتمال ركود اقتصادي يتجاوز ال
35% فاذا دخلنا في ركوب اقتصادي يمكن ايضا
ان يكون هذا واحد من العوامل التي تنبها
الشخص لكي يقوم يشتري
السبب الثالث معدلات التضخم المرتفعه لانه
اذا اخذنا مثلا لشخص عنده 100,000 درهم
الان في البنك اذا كان هنالك تضخم 4% همم
هيحصل انخفاض للقوه الشرائيه فيتحوط
بالشراء بشراء الذهب لكي يتفادى
التضخميهاش او تحوط مقابل التظلم هذه
ثلاثه اسباب رئيسيه انا اتوقع هي التي
تدفع اسعار الذهب بالارتفاع
شلون جزيلا لك على وجودك معنا في الاستديو
عبد العظيم منور متخصص في الاسواق الماليه
والمعدن الثمينه شكرا لكم شكرا لك